[Music]
we who try to be decent people are
bombarded by some kind of moral
political pressure from two sides first
there is the worst one of course this
[Music]
anti-immigrant populist side like why
should we even allow refugees in it's
their fault third-world trouble and so
on there are enough poor people here
they come from another civilization
it means conflict and so on and so on so
there is all the time this pressure of
we are defending our way of life
refugees are disturbing it and it's
interesting how in some radical
right-wing circles we really have
already new conspiracy theories which
always fascinate me in their madness
a couple of weeks ago the main slogan
and coming from Slovenia right-wing
weekly journal something like Slovene
Time magazine published a comment by a
guy which was a ferocious attack on
George Soros the humanitarian
billionaire claiming that his the most
disgusting despicable and dangerous
person today in the world because he is
a Jew who is organizing Muslim invasion
into Europe the guy uses totally open
brutal terms like negret Islamist horde
are invading Europe claiming that the
Jewish plan is to destroy Christian
Europe and they are using Muslims to do
it why do I like
I mean don't misunderstand me I'm
horrified at it but why do I undergo
Denmark's like this fantasy because it
goes to the end and it brings together
two different levels of conspiracy
theory one is Muslim invasion of Europe
and the other is anti-semitism you
really we think that there is some kind
of a conflict in the Middle East between
Palestinians or Muslims and Jews this
theory claims this is absurd the
conflict to delude us in reality even
the Muslim terrorists all of them
I see so hurt Zionist creation to ruin
Europe you know in the good
old-fashioned or Stalinist way you know
how firstly spoke about plutocratic
Bolshevik plot you bring the opposites
together they are doing this so not to
get lost this is one blackmail but then
now things get much more problematic for
some liberal leftist then there is the
other blackmail the humanitarian
blackmail like poor suffering immigrants
coming to Europe desperate is Europe
still Europe is it losing its heart how
can we see all those people suffering
and so on and so on
I basically of course agree with this
second position I nonetheless think
there is something terribly wrong in
this automatic retranslation of I don't
want to call it crisis but whatever you
call it what's happening with refugees
into a pure humanitarian problem which
is out there from somewhere we don't
even analyze it closely thousands
hundreds of thousand people are coming
and it's purely a humanitarian question
do we let them in or not I question this
on all levels
first I'm absolutely ready to admit that
even crucial that it's not simply
something horrible happening in third
world or in this case in Middle East as
we say in Europe in our arrogant way
they screwed it up and now we should pay
the bill
or what of course Europe but not only
Europe we are deeply responsible for it
look at the old at all regions of crisis
we're less
these are coming from from northern
baton or northern Africa Libya and so on
we Europeans screwed it up with military
intervention then no ice is no refugees
from Syria or Iraq without American
intervention there or without this
global or geopolitical conflict between
Russia and United States others involve
Saudi Arabia Turkey Iran and so on they
are what is behind the Syrian civil war
so again we cannot say there is a
humanitarian crisis there and it's
purely our question of moral sympathy
will we receive them we are deeply
responsible for them first
geopolitically end at a deeper level
economically I mean this brutal direct
colonialism is more or less over but
economic neo colonialism is in a way
stronger than ever we know how big
Western and not only Western also other
powers are destroying local agriculture
and so on and so on like these are
things we don't read a lot about them
but are you aware what's happening now
even in some African countries where
there is starvation like Ethiopia and so
on Western companies and in this case
happily I'm ready to say it's not the
usual culprits Europe and United States
it's more some rich Arab countries like
Saudi Arabia and some Asian countries
like South Korea and so on they're
buying gigantic part of this country's
for agricultural use growing industrial
plants and so on and so on and with
millions of people which who can be
employed for the time being when
production still goes on but when
there's a crisis the everything is
chaotic and shown for me the symbol of
today's world and it's typical how we
talk of all the crisis we read so little
about that crisis is the Republic of
Congo maybe one of the wealthiest can
trees in the world with regard to
natural resources and so on but a
non-existing country central government
doesn't work local warlords rule all in
direct connection with foreign companies
all their precious metals to export and
so on and so on so again this is the
situation out of which refugees are
created and now if anything it's getting
even worse we all sympathize I hope so
20 years ago with the tragedy of
Sarajevo in Ikaruga Slavia a big city of
hundreds of thousand people under siege
like in medieval times simply circular
bombarded ok but what's happening now in
Aleppo is even worse in a way it's a
really big city of almost 2 million
people and at least out of egotism we
should worry more are we aware what kind
of explosive new refugee crisis is being
prepared there so again I buy all this
on the other hand I now comes the
problematic part I don't believe that
first that we are the only culprit
because it's not simply us Western
Europeans Americans and Arabs there is a
mega class division rich countries poor
countries corruption among Arabs
themselves and as some people pointed
out you cannot simply say you know in
many left liberals enjoyed it they have
a kind of a perverse pleasure whenever
there is a crisis in a third world
country they always will someway prove
oh it's our responsibility there is
something so patronizing in this as if
as if they are even too stupid all those
Arabs or black Africans to be really
evil if they do something catastrophic
only we are big enough Indian in the
direction of the evil
do it so let's take this case let's ask
a simple question which some people
don't like to ask under immediately
beneath below the big crisis region
Syria Iraq under a couple of Arab Muslim
countries who are among the richest in
the world take Qatar where they control
their own al-jazeera who all the time
emphasizes the plight of immigrants and
so on
Qatar usually is listed among the first
three per capita with greatest per
capita income richest countries in the
world competition is somewhere
Liechtenstein in Europe katara Singapore
ok you know how many refugees they took
none all of them Saudi Arabia Kuwait
Qatar only Amira's none only the poor
countries are invaded by them so I don't
think this is this question should be a
taboo like what is the international
geopolitical game that is being played
here this first point second point
so-called Muslim fundamentalism you know
we should not simply say it's not ok of
course I am NOT condemning it in a
racist way but it's also not enough to
say ok this is just a reaction to
Western imperialism
so ultimately again we are guilty of
course in such reaction but listen let
me draw a parallel Hitler was also just
a reaction to brutal Western imperialism
treatment of Germany after World War one
it's absolutely clear in this sense
Western Europe England France were
responsible for Hitler but this doesn't
mean that we did they were wrong to
fight it afterwards and it's the same
way way here you know
Arabs were exploited all that all that
but nonetheless Muslim fundamentalism is
not simply just a pure passive reaction
to a difficult predicament it's
nonetheless a conscious choice it's a
certain active politics it's a way in a
very strong sense to react to - what -
modern crisis so for me instead of
accepting this official coordinates on
the one hand we Western permissive
society on the other hand Beck
fundamentalist a more radical question
is what is fundamentalism today in what
sense it is generated by inner
antagonisms of global capitalism listen
even in the United States you probably
know a simple it's not a theory but
great book Thomas Frank what happened
with or in purgatory Kansas this is the
enigma Kansas which were lost for over a
century the quintessentially progressive
American state from anti slavery slavery
campaigns and so on in the last 3040
years it becomes the very bedrock of new
Christian fundamentalism and so if you
look at numbers of fundamentalists in
the United States they are pretty much
the same in percentage some three four
percent as the number of radicals and
the mentalists among Arab countries and
so on first we should approach the
problem in this more fundamental way not
simply blaming Islam and so on Islam is
a problematic religion but every
religion is problematic I think we are
living today in an era of I'm not afraid
to speak as a leftist model conservative
an era of ethical decay disintegration
of ethical substance were things which
were simply unimaginable decades ago can
be said or done today let's take an
example
the example of a state which boasts
itself is the only island of reason in
that area of the Middle East do you know
that the highest religious authority of
the Army in the army of a country
they're set to three months ago I
checked it with my friends it's not a
hoax it grew that when the army of their
country occupies another length of
people soldiers have the right to rape
local women there now you will say who
was this Isis now the big lobby of IDF
of Israeli Defense Forces and I mean the
truth are with all my disagreement with
the politics of their government now
they are the ultimate people of
civilization but you see even they are a
part of this decay and so so that I
don't lose the threat the first thing to
do with refugees is to locate them in
this global economic ideological
political situation the second thing is
nonetheless not to make a taboo of the
fact that they are not just passive
victims ok day by day I mean here not
refugees as such but the those among
them who clearly are fundamentalist and
we should debate this issues openly the
third thing and that may be the crux of
the misunderstanding why people attack
me the third point is look we tend to
forget that we all are not just abstract
free individual citizens of a world we
do live as part of concrete communities
with certain ways of life which are
focused which are focused precisely on
ways of enjoyment of how you sexual
relations are regulated all that that's
very core of a community and we are
different here so we should not avoid
all this quest
since of for example Muslims Muslim
Arabs entering Europe they come with
their customs and okay the politically
correct way is to say we should leave
them their customs we have our customs
we should elevate ourselves above these
differences and drafts taker of
fundamental equality human rights and so
on this I claim doesn't work because
human rights are universal values are
never abstractly elevated above concrete
ways of life like examples that you get
in Germany I write about them in my book
over 2000 girls per year of immigrants
to Germany who go to ordinary German
high schools escape from home because
they were more seduced by the Western
Way of life visit nightclubs have german
boyfriends and so on and then their
families put pressure on them like we
know in what sense
and then they escape secretly with the
police do know that they already have
over 20 safe houses in Germany where
these girls are provided with fake ID
and so on and so on and of course Muslim
community cries oh you are ruining our
way of life let's be frank in a way they
are right I mean you cannot impose on
Muslim on a Muslim community our Western
notions of freedom of women to choose
their sex partners whether and claim we
respect your way of life the way the
family deal deals with a woman is the
very basic component of their way of
life I'm not saying there is an easy way
out here but I'm just saying that you
seem upon that the problem is real here
the problem is real and I think we and
also I know the Muslim intolerance is
often exaggerated and then there is a
big story of intolerance of Western
people to Bob's Muslim but
also the other side of the story for
example I learned this from leftists in
in Berlin in Sweden in Denmark and in an
in Nederland Muslim communities they're
attacking gay parades
not when they see public display of
homosexuality and so on and so on so you
see what I mean what I'm simply
advocating it loss of course not
oppressing refugees on behalf of our
Western standards but I hope you admit
you have to set a certain limit and it's
a difficult limit it has to be
renegotiated like I don't know when a
girl who doesn't want to be veiled is
forced by her family to wear well and
she comes to German police and complains
you have to decide you say no that's
their problem or do you say no we
respect a certain notion of feminine
freedom the right we will not tolerate
that whatever you do it will be very
painful I'm claiming this if we don't
approach these topics openly in a public
debate we are just feeding the
anti-immigrant populist racist and we
will get in 1020 years a terrible Europe
where the predominant force will be
anti-immigrant populist
so again my point is not we are
incompatible with immigrants let not
have them in Europe now we can have even
more immigrants but we should absolutely
talk about these problems in an open way
not not ignore these problems ignoring
these problems means you leave the space
open for anti-immigrant populist and
then you have this utter catastrophe of
literally divided Nations were simply
the left
the liberal left's attitude is as if if
you just mentioned this problems they
claim no this is anti-immigrant
Islamophobic racism disappeared or
problems no ordinary people experience
his problems and we have to also address
those concerns I'm not talking here as a
right-wing populist on the opposite if I
make a quick jump to American politics
that's why although I know he we
shouldn't expect too much from Bernie
Sanders but my admiration for Bernie
Sanders was that he mobilized for a
progressive project precisely those
ordinary small has impoverished farmers
workers who are who I dearly vote for
the new populist Republican right the
Christmas see Bernie Sanders opened up
the scope of the terrain for progressive
course for the left outside all this
academic LGBT whatever and included into
it also ordinary impoverished people who
are the ideal prey of right-wing
populists for me everything politically
defect depends on this we have to
struggles today once which unfortunately
are not combined with us one struggle is
all the struggle against sexism and so
on gay rights and the other struggle is
the struggle Sora
let's call poor people economic struggle
third-world and so on and the most
tragic thing I write about this is my
book if you I hope you noticed it it's
when third-world countries advocate
controlling women homophobia and so on
as part of their anti-colonialism no no
this like the ridiculous
example of this is Mugabe who openly
stands for it but you having
kenia in all those countries were openly
the very notion of women's rights gay
rights is dismissed as neo-colonialist
strategy of ruining the local
communities of destroying local ways of
life and so on and so on but if this
problem will not be resolved if we will
be caught in our politically correct
struggle against discrimination and so
on and keeping this at a distance from
basic economic social struggles then we
are doomed
[Music]